[Music]
you have probably already watched the
Disney movie Mulan but even though we'll
probably never know if this woman really
existed we know that her story has been
told during the way dynasty from 386 to
557 ad there are many different versions
of this tale and this is why we are
going to tell you all about them make
sure you watch the whole video to know
how the story ended if you love Milan as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we are showing you the messed
up origins of Mulan
the beginning her story has been told
for centuries and this is what makes
Mulan one of the most legendary women of
ancient China but how did it all start
you probably remember the Disney movie
in which Milan's family expected her to
become a good housewife for her future
husband unfortunately she didn't pass
the test with the matchmaker and
everyone was disappointed this was when
she realized that she had better things
to do but in the original ballad Mulan
was simply washing clothes when she
heard that the army was recruiting new
soldiers one man from every family her
father was too old to survive the war so
she decided to take his place in another
version of the tale she saw on posters
that the Khan was calling troops and she
saw her father's name on the list as he
didn't have any grown-up sons she wanted
to serve in the Army in her father's
place no matter what in both cases
her family knew that she was planning to
do this and then had nothing against
this idea there was nothing wrong with a
young woman going to war and they
probably already knew that this is where
she belonged the war in the Disney movie
Mulan was not better than anyone else
when she decided to go to war she was
really unskilled with weapons and had to
learn how to be a man but she had more
ambition than any other and this is when
she trained harder to achieve her goals
but in the original tale the young woman
really knew what she was doing in one
version of the tale her father thought
that women should know how to fight too
and this is why she was said to have
practice with different weapons the war
hero was known for practicing martial
arts such as kung fu and was also
skilled with a sword in another tale she
even had the chance to go
war with a sword inherited from the
ancestors of the family in another
version of the Ballad of Mulan she
simply bought a horse a saddle a bridle
and a long whip and decided to leave her
family for a couple of years oh and as
you can guess there was no small dragon
or funny cricket to help her in the
original story but you'll have to stay
tuned to know for how many years she was
part of the army and what happened at
the end the love story if you watched
the Disney movie based on Mulan you
probably know that she fell in love with
the army captain foolish Aang in the
second movie they got married and were
directed by the Emperor to escort his
three daughters to a neighboring Kingdom
where they could get married but was
this actually part of the original tale
it's an only one version of this story
that we can hear about him it is
believed that during the war Mulan met
an officer named Jim Yong and fell in
love with him however things were a
little complicated as everyone believed
that she was a man and Yong was only
interested in marrying a woman but after
a couple of years on the battlefield
Mulan was promoted to general and people
learned that she was actually a woman
we'll talk about that gender reveal
shortly after this was when young became
more attached to her they both started
dreaming about getting married to each
other however we don't know if they ever
tied the knot and any of these stories
we have to admit that we think that
Mulan story is even better when she
doesn't need a man we prefer the version
where she has no one in her heart and no
one in her mind but would be ready to do
anything for only one man her father you
don't need a prince to be a Disney
Princess the gender-reveal in the Disney
movie pretending to be a man to join the
army was punishable by death
however Shang spared her life and she
was expelled from the army until she
found another way to help them but how
did people react to this gender reveal
in the original tale in the love story
Jinyoung quickly found out that Mulan
was a woman and simply became more
attached to her and dreamed about
marrying her this is why we can guess
that her gender was not a problem for
him but other soldiers also started to
find out that Mulan was actually a woman
this was wife one day before a difficult
battle their general decided to go on to
the
filled in women's clothes she didn't
want to hide her true identity anymore
the soldiers were not shocked actually
they really respected and admired her
for her bravery they couldn't believe
that one of the best members of the army
was actually a woman and this is what
inspired them to win another battle in
other versions of this tale move on
simply wore her old-time clothes when
she came back home and her soldiers were
inspired to find out that she was a
woman we think that the Disney movie
would have been more inspiring if
soldiers didn't care about Milan's
gender but only cared about how good she
was be ending in the Disney movie Mulan
was praised by the Emperor and the
inhabitants of the city after saving
China she then declined his offer to
become his advisor and asked to return
to her family to present the gifts to
her father most of the original tales
are similar but some of them are more
tragic than others in the Ballad of
Mulan the war hero actually fought for
12 years in the army and even became a
general she was offered many gifts but
the only thing she wanted was a horse
she took off her wartime gown and put on
her old-time clothes this is when some
soldiers came to see her and realize
that she was actually a woman but in
another version of this tale Mulan
returned home only to find out that her
father had passed away he didn't feel
like a hero but only thought that she
lost the love of her life and was
haunted by her experiences on the
battlefield this is how her life ended
tragically
so which tell do you prefer the Disney
movie or the original story don't be shy
to answer in the comment section down
below we'd love to hear what you think
and that's it for the messed up origins
of Mulan for more stories like this make
sure you watch the messed up origins of
The Little Mermaid
thanks for watching and see you next
time
you